Speaker 1: lk about this every day, but there
is something very interesting happening with
this forthcoming CNN town hall with Donald Trump.
Yesterday, I told you that CNN has announced they
will be holding a town hall with failed former
and wannabe future President Donald Trump. And I
express concerns that they're treating him like
he's a normal person. They're treating him like
he's just yet another presidential candidate,
not a guy who incited a riotous insurrection,
not a guy who's been indicted and arrested
once and potentially will be again
now getting another 24 hours of
time for CNN to promote this event.
They're really pretending like he is a
normal candidate. Here is a promo from
yesterday morning on CNN, including the thoughts
of Kaitlan Collins, who will be the host or anchor
of that forthcoming town hall.
Speaker 2: So quick programing
notice on top of all this, as we were watching
politics so closely here for President Trump
is going to take questions from New Hampshire
primary voters and an exclusive see it in town
hall. I'm in a moment. Next Wednesday, May
10th, at 9 p.m. Eastern. So looking forward
to seeing that. Really important for him to
take voter questions. He is the front runner
right now in the GOP. New overnight, Sam. Yeah.
Speaker 1: So listen, he's the GOP frontrunner.
It's that simple. Is going to be
interesting to hear him answer. Oh,
how will you keep an undocumented immigrants
out? This is not looking particularly good. It
looks like this is becoming 2016 Part two
The normalization of absolute extremism.
Our Argentinean friend who's been a guest on the
program, expert on fascism, Federico Finkelstein,
tweeted, quote, This is how the normalization
of wannabe fascist populism happens. And then
here is a little promo on CNN for the event.
Speaker 2: Former President Donald Trump takes
questions live from CNN's Kaitlan Collins. And
New Hampshire GOP primary voters. Their issues,
their concerns, their votes. A CNN
Republican presidential town hall.
Speaker 1: There you go. So like I said yesterday,
I totally understand why CNN is doing this. It
couldn't be better timed. You've got millions
of people furious with Fox News because of they
they fired Tucker and these different things.
They've gone woke. They settled the Dominion
lawsuit and they're looking for somewhere to go.
And maybe that somewhere is going to be CNN. Now,
as I said before, I'm not opposed on principle
to having an event with Trump, but it must be
handled correctly and responsibly. And it can't
just be. Hey, New Hampshire voters ask about what
Trump's going to do about woke and trends. You
have to make it clear that this is a dishonest.
Paranoid, narcissistic conspiracy theorist with
things in his recent past that have never been
seen from the American presidency and that none of
this is normal. Can Caitlyn Collins do that? Sure.
Will she do it? I don't know. My plan is to cover
the town hall live. I know people will say, but,
David, aren't you doing the same thing CNN
is doing? No. This is a media analysis show
and an American politics show. And one of
the things we do is look at how corporate
media covers something like Trump, and we're
going to be doing it responsibly. And if they
rehabilitate his image and if they don't
do the things that they should be doing,
we will call it out. So my hope is to cover that
live. We might get shut down by CNN. As you know,
that's happened to us in the past with
these exclusive events. But that'll be
next week. We'll take a quick break.
Much more to talk about today first.